what we've been discussing this evening
the government's controversial new
migration legislation designed to try
and ensure those crossing the channel in
small boats are swiftly removed to a
third country like Rwanda well that
passed the commons today there was of
course lots of opposition from labor and
others but also some concerns from some
unconservative Ventures as well now we
can talk to you our next guest who won
some concessions from the government
over unaccompanied children Tim Lawson
joins us now thank you very much for
being with us so how did you vote today
I voted for the bill this bill needs to
go through because we have got to do
something practical to stop this
completely unsustainable and dangerous
business or small boats coming across
the the channel in a disorderly way and
it's tough there are really tough
measures in the in the bill to clamp
down on bogus Asylum Seekers and on the
people Smugglers who are benefiting from
this this tragic trade and I wanted to
balance that with making sure that there
are clearly defined safe and legal
routes which was amendment that I put
down with a lot of colleagues which the
government has accepted so there will be
clearly set out safe legal routes for
genuine Sun Seekers to be able to come
to the UK If particularly if they have a
close connection without having to go in
the small boats I just want take this a
bit for people who might not be familiar
with the phrase safe and legal reads
because the situation as it stands is
that for many countries including places
like Sudan for example that's been used
there aren't any ways for people to
legally claim asylum in the UK right
there are but they're really difficult
so if you come from Hong Kong or Ukraine
they've been the resettlement schemes
and we've taken over 300 000 people from
those two areas and will take a lot more
particularly from Hong Kong if you're
part of the Syria scheme we took on 24
25 000 syrians and gave them safe
passage and brought to the uh to the UK
and then there's the Afghanistan scheme
as well the trouble is with the
Afghanistan scheme where we airlifted I
think at the time about 15 000 people
legally from Kabul Airport in a hurry
something like 9 000 of them 18 months
later are still in hotels so it shows
the problem that how we not just bring
them to the UK safely but then can give
them full-time permanent accommodation
so it's not um it's not easy so there
are routes through family reunion and
through the unhcr the refugee agency but
they're really difficult to get on so
what we want is to make sure we have got
proper safe legal routes widely
advertised much more accessible and
these will be additional to what we've
got now and that's what the government
has agreed so the example that I
challenge the home sector with
notoriously is a months ago what if I'm
a 16 year old orphan from an East
African country with a relative legally
in the UK how would I get to the UK
safely and legally which she's slightly
struggle to answer that hypothetical
situation became a reality this week
with Sudan that 16 year old is actually
happening um now so we need to make sure
that we can pass that 16 year old
Sudanese test for somebody who clearly
isn't Simon Seeker clearly escaping
danger has a connection with the UK if
they've got a relative here so it has a
case to apply for Asylum to the UK
that's the sort of person we need and I
think most people would agree because
that we have a duty too because right
now the 16 year old from Sudan can't get
here if they had a relative that can go
through quite an elaborate process they
might stand a chance if they made it to
a unhcr refugee camp or something like
that then they might be able to what we
need to do as we've done in the past
we've done it very successfully in the
in the past is expand family Union
schemes and say to the unhcr we are
prepared to take on from Sudan or
whatever X number of um of genuine
refugees please go and identify for them
and we'll arrange them to come over here
and that's the sort of thing we're going
to get in the future now now our level
with you
when I wake up interview ministers they
say yes we're going to open more say
from legal routes yeah yeah yeah it's
gonna happen it's gonna happen no right
now we can't say what they are we can't
say how we're going to do it but it's
going to happen
do you actually believe them yes it's
got to happen so what the amendment that
I got through today says ideally what I
wanted it to to do is that when this
bill goes into law and all the tough
measures come in the safe and legal
routes are ready to kick into into
action I didn't get that because there's
a lot of work still to be done but what
the amendment does guarantee is that
within six months of the bill going
through the government would have had to
properly consult with local authorities
and others to see what we can take and
how we're going to accommodate them it's
not a case of bringing them here but how
are we going to look after those at
those people and what those safe and
legal routes are going to look like how
people will be able to access access
them uh and and get to the uh to the UK
and they will start next year and that's
a bit of a gap but actually it's a clear
undertaking that will now be on the face
of the bill and the government will be
beholden to and we'll make sure that
happens you'll make sure it happens how
you can do that you're going to be on
the case well if it if they don't
produce those details when the bill goes
to the House of Lords this bill is going
to get a tough time in the House of
Lords it's a controversial bill it's
necessarily tough there are going to be
many more changes to it before it
becomes law but if people want safe and
legal routes this bill now offers it so
there's got to be a compromise in the in
the laws we've got more detail from the
government as to how they what they're
going to look like
in order to get it through the Lord so
these safe liquids can can start so I'm
confident we we're trusting ministers to
produce it they've said there's going to
be an annual voting Parliament as to how
many refugees we can sustainably
um take on we want to do this but we
want to make sure we're taking on the
right people genuine refugees escaping
persecution Civil War Sudan uh who have
a connection with the UK and that's what
this does
Andrew Mitchell earlier said that the
government is testing the limits and his
words of international law I mean some
would say that they're breaking it
well okay so there's an issue about the
European convention and this problem
when we try and Deport people then at
the last minutes there is an interim
Junction produced under the echr by an
anonymous European
um judge and that's happened so many
times and that grounded the Rwanda
flights which hadn't started
um yet
those section 39 injunctions they used
to be called temporary
injunctions are not actually part of the
European convention they are an internal
process of the European convention
system
everybody Raves about the echr over the
last 10 years there are more than 400
convention rulings that have not been
complied with we are one of the best
compliers with convention rulings of I
think only nine outstanding rulings we
haven't complied with which includes
like things like giving votes to
prisoners which in Parliament we voted
against because I and most people don't
actually believe in in Spain I think the
figures from like 61 percent of those
major monies not being complied with
initially it's 58 France Germany is very
highly that's not how law works but what
I'm saying is we have only not complied
with a very small number a lot of value
European countries have not complied
with a very large number but we're the
ones who are in the in the frame and the
convention knows they've got to change
their methods as well we are out of time
always interesting to talk to you thank
you very much for being on the program